the International Space Station just
beat mission control in a chess game
playing from space where astronauts
Woody hoberg who shared the game on
Twitter with amazing photos Frank Rubio
Sultan al-nayadi and Steve Bowen they
played against mission control on the
ground each team made about one move per
day with the flight controllers moving
the pieces for the astronauts in
addition to being historic the game was
pretty cool featuring some great moments
and a nice Final Touch Mission Control
got a nice Advantage but the ISS shocked
them with an opposant capture mission
control then overreacted by aggressively
posting up their Bishop it couldn't be
captured but it didn't need to be and
after a follow-up mistaken attack on the
Queen the ISS made a new Queen winning a
rook in the process upper Rook the ISS
finished nicely By ignoring this bishop
capture with check definitely
sidestepping and keeping a threat
against the queen and a threat of
Checkmate in one which is exactly how
the game ended game two is now underway
so we look forward to updates on that
from space